our lives are powerfully affected by a
special quirk of the human mind to which
we rarely pay much attention we are
creatures deeply marked by our
expectations we go around with mental
pictures lodged in our brains of how
things are supposed to go we may hardly
even notice we've got such phantasms but
expectations have an enormous impact on
how we respond to what happens to us
what drives us to fury our affronts to
our expectations there are plenty of
things that don't turn out to be as we'd
like but don't make us livid either when
a problem has been factored into our
expectations calm is not endangered we
may be sad but we're not screaming
unfortunately our expectations are never
higher and therefore more troublesome
than they are in love our expectations
in relationships might go like this a
decent partner should easily intuitively
understand what I'm concerned about I
shouldn't have to explain things at
length to them if I've had a difficult
day I shouldn't have to say that I'm
worn out and need a bit of space they
should be able to tell how I'm feeling
they shouldn't oppose me if I point out
that one of our acquaintances is a bit
stuck-up
they shouldn't start defending them
they're meant to be constantly
supportive when I feel bad about myself
they should show me up and remind me of
my strengths a decent partner won't ever
make too many demands they won't be
constantly requesting that I do things
to help them out or dragging me off to
do something I don't like will always
like the same things I don't have pretty
good taste in films food and household
routines my lover will understand and
sympathize with these at once and then
of course you get into relationship and
the problems start a solution to our
distress and agitation
therefore lies in a curious area with a
philosophy of pessimism
it's an order unabie lling thought
pessimism sounds so unattractive is
associated with failure it's usually
what gets in the way of better things
but when it comes to relationships
expectations are the enemies of love a
more moderate more reasonable set of
expectation
about love would include a range of
ideas for example the idea that it's
normal and largely unavoidable that
people don't understand one another very
well in a couple each person's mind is a
hugely complex and convoluted place it's
hard to grasp exactly why someone acts
as they do and by extension we'd be
assuming from the start that no partner
is going to have a complete reliable or
terribly accurate understanding of us
there will be the occasional things they
get right but these will be the
exceptions rather than the standard as a
relationship developed we then wouldn't
get hurt when our partner made some
wildly inaccurate assumptions about our
needs or preferences
we'd have been assuming that this would
be coming along pretty soon from the
start we'd ideally have an assumption
that in any relationship there would be
significant areas of disagreement which
could well turn out to be irresolvable
we wouldn't particularly relish this
it's not that we'd be eager to get
together with someone with whom we're at
odds but we just assumed that we weren't
going to find someone who'd be on the
same wavelength as us on every serious
issue that cropped up we'd know that a
good working relationship would not mean
blanket agreement love begins with the
discovery of harmony in some very
specific and beautiful areas but to
continue with this expectation is to
doom love to a slow death the error
we're always tempted to make is to see
defects as special to our own partner we
get to know the irritating and
disappointing sides of one particular
person and then draw the conclusion that
we've been especially unlucky we've
become involved with someone who seemed
lovely on the surface but then in time
revealed themselves strangely disturbed
and defective or a curse what a problem
to correct we therefore start looking
around for a new partner with whom we
can finally have what we always knew was
promised to us a problem-free
relationship our romantic impulses are
continuously and dangerously being
renewed and we blame everything but our
hopes and yet the reasons why other
people in love are disappointing are
universal the problems may take on a
local cat
rector but everyone would have them in
the broad to a significant extent we
don't need to know the specific
eccentricities we would find in a
prospective partner but we can be sure
that there will be some and they will at
points prove pretty serious the only
people we can think of as normal of
those we don't yet know very well
you